yeah as for the sound effect for how
he's doing like his life yeah and he did
a similar thing that you do where he
went oh really
why like well right minds think likes
yeah right well what do you watch the
sound fairy my sticks let's just sound
the fact for your life bro how I'm is
usually like in 1940 yeah I know that I
know that the audience can see it from
the back it's more impressive from the
back okay right and boppin nation
yeah of animation oh wow and then no oh
it blew up the Sun the guy who's gonna
catch the ball wow that's your sound
effect yep that's an amazing getting it
out of the No alright that was very
visual so far that it went to this one
that you bit somebody's chin off once
yeah I did
alright well in a street fight I was
growing up in Scotland I don't see I
don't believe that you're gonna see
Holland in the 1960 you have no accent
when I was 20
well I got rid of 20 how old would that
make you dude right now you'd be 65 I'm
35 years old so 30
[Laughter]
and Brian they're done and what a great
song Brian this the first time he's ever
heard they're in cloaks they're in the
forest and these people are literally
having gay sex in coffins okay they're
swimming in feces okay is is this alex
jones harris and your friend joe rogan
yeah who's literally reading the george
soros talking points and he said he'd
have me back on the show i don't need to
be on the show okay well I have sundar
Pichai the CEO of Google yeah and Google
is evil and you know this because you're
part of this exact trap travesty is what
I would call it and it's a conspiracy on
what people who come to this planet just
using it as a search engine they're bad
people and they're lizards fat people
and then they're not human okay do you
have any Z evidence scientific evidence
for this you have any let me tell you
the scientific evidence that I've found
the bad people of above lizard people
[Laughter]
lizards living among us stuck and your
friend Joe Rogan yeah ooh and Joe's a
brilliant guy yeah
Joseph Joe knows as much as I do amen
and and he's a well-read guy right and a
nice and he's talking about DMT and he
wants to start a concentration camp no I
don't know I don't think that's strife
don't you a long time I mean where Joe
Rogan where lives up in Valencia where
he has a concentration live in Cottle
any concentration tail I can tell you
that is George Soros plant
I got a clam it's just like the story of
the Scorpion and the Frog yeah I know
the Scorpion says hey to the Frog get me
across the water yeah and he gets on the
frog and the scorpion stings the Frog
yeah and the fan of frog says why did
you sting me and he says cuz I'm a
scorpion it's in my nature
you're a it's in my nature you're a
scorpion and a joke Joe Rogan is a
scorpion all right scorpion people the
furniture you haven't got much to spare
who cares what I'm oh my god yeah all
right good nice yeah yeah no I've never
been down there right what do they call
they call lobsters bugs out there yeah
they do well they're in the boat of
Resident [ __ ] up about animals I'm just
talking about Australia
why do we call them bugs cuz yeah I'm
tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you
been doing shut up Brian
will you finally give a [ __ ] well well
kind of will yeah let's see what I said
to [ __ ] Chris D'Elia
Oh serious man yeah who who's that
listen if you're feeling froggy you got
a head and leap all right now you're
looking for trouble can you be in
disrespect downing water table here
trouble here okay drop here let me tell
you something what you remember a while
back
speaking Tim in a podcast thank you for
sitting in for Tommy blotchy and
remember the time that you wrote a
letter to Chad Kultgen
because years ago we're working on a
project and Chad and I was training in
mixed martial arts
yes and Muay Thai yes let's be let's be
clear I was a guy in his you know mid
30s training in my time yeah just kind
of rolling around you know just having
my trainer Harold Dimond you know yeah
you would kick the bag and so nice
Harold diamond would say that kick right
there would split somebody's liver yeah
yeah yeah sure good times brought the
thing about it is I was just like a big
you know just a big sloppy fat dude in
the gym don't be that mean yourself I'm
not I'm a pragmatist I'm a realist okay
and you wrote a letter to Chad Chad said
if I had a year term I'll be able to put
will and really choke and you explain to
him the difference between a dog and a
bear you wrote him an email
si well he wrote your trainer he wrote
he wrote my coaching who's a writer and
is about five seven and though he's not
510 he's not 510 yeah it's a ridiculous
thing to say no he's a babe I'm 11 I let
me go with will on this cuz you're
always five every time seven without
question
there's no no no probably about 510 okay
let's let's just be five nine he's five
nine one 71-65 okay I'll put him at 185
your stop just walking six walk around
yeah if you saw me man
any regular guy and not a regular got
baseball played some base a hell of a
baseball player there's a thick dude
please mister he played baseball up
until last year and he's
I think I could take well if I train and
I had to explain to him that that just
wouldn't happen you wrote him in the
essay I wrote Chapman saying nothing
else no I wrote him a long essay called
out do yoga in the bed Ottoman Baron
that he posted on his website because it
was it was it was well-received in the
same way the guy was dead serious that
he could be well yeah dad is always
serious I can take a minute I I haven't
met this guy no I don't believe so he's
a he's fantastic writer producer and he
his his contention was he wasn't saying
this would definitely be what happened
but he said he goes I think if I had a
year to Train and I put on what he said
something ridiculous he said like 20
pounds of mom she's in crisis right
yeah but he's just yeah and he'd never
had any training so he's just a big
fight fan you know he's a huge MMA fan
and but he also said he could you could
potentially beat a whale in a fight well
if I got if I got my fingers deep in its
I I feel like it would be like and then
I would kind of technically we're in the
fight so his point was thought he could
take willed like here's I had to explain
him that will is if will was motivated
and strong will would world's very hard
to hurt for a guy's never really punch
here you know tough and I said also that
we'll wanted to he said you're a
prideful man but you need to understand
the way the universe works a dog ain't
beat beating a bear a silverback ain't
here in a peep out of a chimp either
yeah not a peep and didn't get through
to this guy yeah yeah Chad said uh you
know I'm telling you very realistic I
did win but a lot of this stuff don't
save enough read it 50 times because dub
Davidoff couldn't believe that his
friend Bryan Callen would take this much
time to break down yeah the shoe man let
it stay but one of the things I always
say about you is that when guys when
guys who are regular guys have played
some sports and have some pride will say
well how would how would you do against
Brendan I go are you asking really how
you would do against Brendan and then
they go yeah what I go I go what you
need to know about him and it's not it's
a hard thing for you to hear as a man is
that if Brendan wanted to [ __ ] you he
could [ __ ] it's great he's interviewing
I think Dan
hi the weirdest leg cramp just that huh
well good yeah yeah these little chairs
man alright bro these little [ __ ]
chairs right though you know Brendan
fits and I'm just taking yeah Brendan's
a big guy but Brendan's not you know
Brendan is is uh he's V doubt yeah you
know he's he's got the [ __ ] shape in
all the right places yeah it does have a
bubble ass yeah right but he's got mine
but he's got narrow man hips and [ __ ]
and he's got those glutes that [ __ ]
yeah come together and just press his
[ __ ] no room for his balls alright
just saying Brendan's got a nice [ __ ]
set everything all right and he I'm sure
he fits fine and I see that the show or
pictures of you guys on the you know on
the sets like everyone looks so
comfortable and then I come here and
it's like I'm sitting coach doing a
podcast can't you can't fly coach no I
can't fly coach you fly first-class I
fly I fly cockpit alright I just go in
and I sit in the corner of the cockpit
and they can't get yeah I'm good don't
worry about me I'm not gonna cause any
trouble yeah yeah and they go yeah you
just sit there on the ground like a
[ __ ] giant teddy you still got your
bull Hardcastle
yeah I still got huge guys yeah we're
gonna stop the you know the Alita though
blah blah blah and everybody loves it
because everybody loves impersonations
you know I come by here and I do in
person yeah yeah I know I know it's a
good time what is the nicest thing
Donald has ever said to you the nicest
thing Donald is that we were mar-a-lago
yeah and I was dining with him and
Ivanka and and Melania and the whole
finisher Baron the boy was eating
chicken strips huh and and he said he
complimented me on how I ate my Caesar
salad I was out well I like the way you
eat your Caesar salad you separate the
shrimp from the Caesar salad I know that
you asked specifically for no croutons
you're watching your carb intake and
then you eat the salad first what's the
thought behind that and I said it's
important you gotta eat your vegetables
and your fruits first because they
digest a little faster right yeah so you
don't want the protein underneath ya the
pros stick in your bowel yes sticking
and then the the
vegetables will sit on top and then you
get all farty yeah and Baron laughs
because I said farty and he's like I
want you around another time you and
Baron you're gonna teach a matter
through a football you're gonna be the
man that can't be the father I can okay
so that's I'm Aaron's Godfather I know
that wrote the speech modulations you
get paid to be his Godfather Allah it's
like the toy remember that Richard bye
dudes watch the toy what is the meanest
thing Donald's ever said to you oh he
called me Chris Christie once when I was
coming off as jet backwards sorry he saw
my ass and he thought it was Chris Chris
oh that's me to get back in the jet
Chris you fat [ __ ] and I was like what
and he's a good in there Chris Christie
well well oh hey what's up Willie baby
and then because you're really baby yeah
we have all sorts of nickname you got
some different different fight styles
for sure I know I'm cruising at about
206 right now but bro oh yeah Bros you
know you wear 206 well thank you thank
you thank you man thank you I feel
that's all I wanted Brian thank you I
feel you live a hundred pounds I'm one
man but pound of what I feel a lion buy
a hunt pounds okay man that's not cool
six I'm a heavyweight yeah I'm a big guy
cool sick why can't you be positive
beers I feel like you where's 206 well
you know I'm having I'm haven't got a
little bit of a salt and balance problem
right now coupled with possibly a
thyroid condition and you know I mean oh
I'm a little bit of a heavier guy but I
am I'm sorta I enjoy savory foods yeah
and I know I might be a little a little
a little bigger than I normally am yeah
I got to get down for the summer I gotta
get you know I got a there's a couple
places I want to go in to get check out
I know you like Bora Bora yeah I want to
take Kelly Anne there I don't know about
the Steve Perry [ __ ] but I'm about
206 right now but I will say bro I'm
only about Brody Brown's heavier than
you yeah that's interesting yeah Brendan
looks way thicker around the midsection
yeah you gotta give me that look like UK
206 better and I can hear that's here I
feel like I'm bi we've all played beach
volleyball before you gotta admit I look
a little thinner around the midsection
and Brendan I don't have a mat that I'm
not gonna grease out your
I'm about 206 I know that bro we were
talking about nutrition he said he's
he's a 3% body fat which I think it's
interesting because he's 297 pounds a
630 297 Wow and three percent body fat
so I know you can spin kick the [ __ ] out
of a boxing Bob your face stationary
know about that I know that we got some
footage coming of Brendan hitting your
face with the focus pads I know we're
gonna see that we're gonna see your face
as a target right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]